more information
is coming out from the fine work of
investigative uh business journalists as
you know tether is a stable coin what's
a stable coin it's a type of
cryptocurrency where uh the price of the
coin stays stable
one tether or one usdc should equal one
dollar
in american currency us dollars so there
has been quite a controversy because
tether has become so big it's one of the
top five to ten uh crypto projects in
terms of market cap it's got a market
cap uh that's been over 60 billion and
they were supposed to be as we all know
backed one to one with dollars uh and it
turned out they were
changed that rule and they were back to
maybe three or four percent by dollars
where's the other 90
it's in equities maybe maybe it's in
something called commercial paper which
is loans to other businesses anyway
there's been a lot of
um investigation into this company
because people consider it perhaps
a black swan or a systematic uh or some
sorry systemic risk the crypto space
because so much of crypto
uses these essentially you can think of
them as a casino chips right if you go
to vegas you get casino chips from the
aria and you happen to wind up at the
bellagio or at the bellagio and you wind
up at the wind they'll kind of change
those chips for you i don't know if you
knew that and you don't have to carry
ten thousand dollars in cash you could
have ten one thousand dollar chips or
two 5k chips called flags in your
pockets that's what this was the
equivalent of a way to just not carry
around large amounts of money and use
essentially a shadow currency um
and tether was banned from operating in
new york city after the attorney general
had a scathing report on them they've
since done attestations to kind of tell
us
um what they have in their holdings but
they were uh one or two pages long and
done by a very questionable
accounting firm from you know the cayman
islands or somewhere offshore uh or
something that i shouldn't say that that
firm is questionable i think people had
many questions about that firm might be
a better way of saying it uh because
it's not pricewarehousecoopers or ernst
young or something like that okay so
anyway this um article came out by a
gentleman named zeke fox he's a
journalist at bloomberg and the title of
the story is anyone seen tethers
billions so let's bring on zeke who's
calling in uh i think from the east
coast perhaps new york hey zeke how are
you doing
hi jason uh thanks for having me on yeah
you're from here in uh brooklyn ah my
hometown uh i lived in brooklyn when it
wasn't cool the 70s and 80s
now you're there and super cool uh so uh
tell me what did you learn in the course
of your reporting
so
i i mean took it back to the start i
wanted to see who founded tether
why it existed what was the point of it
and
i mean on the most extreme side you have
people who are basically saying this is
a giant fraud it's a ponzi scheme
there's probably no money at all then
you have the
crypto people who are like why would you
ever worry about tether it's industry
standard we've been uh
using it for years
and what i found is that
the company that issues the coin i mean
this isn't really some decentralized
thing it's controlled by
one company
and the man who's in charge of the
company his name is giancarlo divisini
you early in his life he was a plastic
surgeon near milan
yeah then he got into like the import
export business
um doing bringing in like low quality
ram from asia
um good
and
then he invested in a uh crypto exchange
one of his employees there helped found
tether and he ended up sort of
buying in buying a bigger share of it so
you've got this guy giancarlo who
controls tether and there's kind of a
conflict of interest at the center of it
which is that like if you
are a person who uses tether your
concern is that
they have the money to cash in the coins
whatever you want you want
tether to always be worth a dollar no
matter what but if you're juan carlo
you want to take the money that people
have given you to buy the tethers
and invest it because any money that
they earn on these reserves
that's their profit it would tether at
69 billion
even if they earned one percent
690 million dollars a year and it's a
really small operation like a couple
dozen employees
so
so they get the float and
that would mean their incentive is to
take more risk
with people's money while the people who
are giving them the money are giving
them the money under the auspices under
the exact promise that there is less
risk in this
and is that what you're saying is the
opposing forces here or the conflict
exactly and so for us tether
it's created as a workaround for banks
but they've always had to have a bank
because they need someone to keep the
money that they're holding reserves and
i spoke to uh
john betts the banker who ran a bank in
puerto rico
which for a couple years was where
tether kept its its money
and he said to me
they he ended up having a falling out
with uh divasini the
tethers chief he said to me
first off
when tether was with this bank the money
was there but
second he compared it to uh
a hedge fund he said um
he said basically it's not a stable coin
it's a hybris hedge fund and like tether
is misrepresenting
um in his view
the risks involved
um
so
once i understood that what i really
wanted to know is like okay what are
they doing with these reserves then
because
you could invest in like treasuries it'd
be pretty safe and you might still earn
like a the pot is so big you could still
earn a decent yield so i wanted to see
now that the question had been raised
like okay maybe they're safe maybe
they're not wanting to see what they're
investing in so i spent a while uh
looking into that
and you in fact uh had somebody tell you
that tether has about 15 billion sitting
with dell tech about 22 percent of their
reserves maybe you could unpack that
yeah so the only bank i could find now
that would say hey we do business with
tether is called deltek and it's a real
bank it's in the bahamas
and its founder is an interesting guy
not its founder it's uh chairman and
largest investor i believe is an
interesting guy his name is jean
chalapin he's uh he's french
he got rich by inventing inspector
gadget
and heathcliff i remember that one yeah
i mean he was like writing these
cartoons he's a he got in
he's uh he sold his animation studio for
a huge amount
um and now later in life he's moved to
the bahamas where for a while he lived
in a
mansion that you might recognize it was
uh
it was the villain's house in casino
royale if you remember like when uh
yeah daniel craig he gets out of the out
of the ocean and that like little uh
yeah the famous homage scene yeah so
okay colorful characters yeah yeah um
they do business with them they however
that chairman says he doesn't know where
the rest of the money is so he's like
yeah we've got about 15 billion that
money is safe we haven't invested it in
anything weird but i don't know where
the rest is let me ask you a question
right so
why would um
the inspector gadget creator
uh
why would he tell you this information
it's like he's not obligated to tell you
right
no i mean he i said hey can i come meet
you in the bahamas and he said uh he
said sure he didn't have to do that and
i appreciate it um
i think his interest is that
he doesn't want people to think his bank
is some
like two-bit operation that has nothing
going on but tether he wanted to see
this is a real bank we have other
customers and like
yes tether's one of them but
they don't own us we did our due
diligence and we we're handling some
money for them
if you listen to twist often you've
heard me talk about odoo's suite of
business apps a lot and they are sweet
well they're going to give you your
first app free forever and a thousand
dollars off your implementation pack at
odoo.com
and here is why odoo is amazing for
startups their suite of business apps
helps you run your entire company on one
platform and they will streamline the
workflows by bringing all your
information together eliminating
annoying repetitive tasks like entering
data across multiple platforms plus if
you only need two or three apps to
optimize your workflow at your startup
well that's all you'll pay for they're
not going to charge you for apps you
don't use of course not
and odoo offers 30 main apps that are
going to get almost everything in your
organization done plus 16 000 apps from
their open source community for those
niche applications that might be unique
to your business their apps include
bookkeeping sales crm website builders
and more so here is your cta the old
call to action again your first app is
free forever and odoo is offering 1 000
right now on your first implementation
pack get that credit right now before
it's gone odo.com
twist